[music]
principles of success an adventurous
ultra mini series in 30 minutes and eight
episodes first episode adventure
calls believe me when i tell you
that in the beginning i had hardly any relevant
knowledge my success in life
is based on my
ability to use my knowledge gaps effectively other
regulations  doing it is presumptuous
i will do it anyway because
my principles of success can also
help others to achieve their goals
i am at a point in life where
i prefer to pass on my knowledge of being
successful instead of
accumulating even more personal successes
you then decide for yourself whether you
want to use these principles
independent thinking is mandatory only
you can set up your own behavioral principles
that are derived from your values
here is my first basic
principle decide for yourself what is true
let's go i recognized early on that the principle of
action  pien needed these
are intelligent methods for
dealing with
situations that keep repeating themselves in similar situations
there are basic methods for everything
from skiing to achieving a child
i will present some of my most important
principles for life from
which everything is derived but
such principles are not my thing  the
cradle was laid
i have developed it based on lifelong
experiences above all
i have learned from mistakes my principles
are simple but incomplete
i constantly strive to make optimal decisions i still make mistakes and
derive new lessons from them that is what
reality is like  first i had to free
myself from the conventions around me
and think independently if
you don't want to live in a life determined by others you have to
make your own decisions and have the
courage to put them into practice
this realization was not the
starting point but the lesson of my
adventure  in my memory i see
how the flow of time pushes us forward
we meet the reality that forces us
to make decisions
we can stop the flow again
nor avoid such encounters
you can only face reality
as best as you can
in life you have to make millions
of making decisions
the quality of those decisions
determines the quality of life the
most valuable lessons of my life
are the result of mistakes
to avoid making the same mistake in the future
i adopted principles of behavior
these principles guided me from
my petty middle-class existence on
long island to a conventionally
successful life
they gave  your meaningful tasks
and relationships which is more important to me
than any conventional success i
am often asked how i
did it you certainly not because i
am something special no i found
my personal approach to life that
almost everyone can use
first you have to d  accepting
and processing reality in the second episode
i explain what it
is all about choosing your own path in life is the
most important decision i wanted to have an
above-average life
boredom and mediocrity were
more repugnant to me than failure
i came from a humble background and
was
therefore frugal  was i able to consciously decide for the
adventure
since my childhood i
pursued my desires failed got up
and went on and failed again
from every failure i learned about
became more skilful high failed less
often the many repetitions
even taught me to like the process itself
failure this is how i met
reality and learned to process it,
which gave rise to another
basic principle truth is the
crucial foundation for good
results truth here
refers to the way our environment
works nature has given us the laws of
reality
man didn't create
them but can use them for his personal evolution
and goals this insight made
me a realist
i realized how rewarding it is to
deeply understand accepting and
processing de facto realities
as opposed to wishful thinking about being
realist doesn't mean i'm in
it  doubt that dreams can come true
quite the opposite without dreams
life is banal
as an over realist one is
optimally able to choose and
realize
dreams big dreams plus acceptance of
reality plus a good dose of
determination create a
successful life
i think this formula is
generally applicable but what does a
successful life look
like everyone has to decide for themselves what
success looks like in their individual case, regardless of whether you
want to be a master of the universe
or prefer life under a palm tree,
it doesn't matter you set goals based on
personal values ​​and then decide
how to achieve them  real  ed we need
practicable decision-making approaches
especially when problems, errors and
weaknesses stand in our way on the way
to success you have to face
reality especially when it is
uncomfortable and unwanted at
first i struggled with the
hard truths
i recognized that psychological
pain  blocked me and that
new perspectives were needed i began
to regard problems as puzzle games at
the end of each game there were
new solutions as a reward that could be
transferred to similar problems
i learned to interpret pain and discomfort as
signals that an important lesson was to be
learned i concluded pain
plus reflection  progress
meditation has
helped me a lot on this path as i heard reality
as it was and me
it lifted my soul pain
and left pure joy everyone has
the capacity to think logically
about themselves and their situation to
reflect and  d directing personal
evolution
there are five simple steps
to follow
more on this in the third episode
we know how important it is to reflect
on the pain I have experienced
certain
laws opened up for me that
prevented me from repeating the same mistakes
I realized  the path to success had
five steps step 1
knowing and pursuing
personal goals personal goals are different
you have to know each other well in order to know
what you want to achieve in life
step 2 confronting problems
on the way to the goal
problems are unpleasantly painful
unsolved they can
mean the end but in order to move forward
problems must be identified not
tolerated
step 3 diagnosis of the problems and
their causes avoid hasty
solutions he is to take a deep breath and differentiate the
symptoms from the illness
step 4 conception of a solution plan
here you define what s  you need
to avoid problems
step 5 execution of the solution concept
now persevere and implement
a successful life consists in the
continuous repetition of these
steps it is about your
personal evolution
you see it everywhere it is just a
natural law
think of a product an
organization or a  person you
know the process works here too
evolution means adapt or die it
is based on the same concept as
the five step approach overcoming the often
difficult process is like
climbing the ladder of
success naturally although i became more and more
adept my struggle never became
easier but more competent  came
with more challenging challenges
because everyone is gifted differently
most of us can't do all five steps
equally well
accept this fact lest you overdo it the
higher you go the lower
you can fall
no one is immune to t  raging
events
they can mean doom or
a change for the better
depending on our reaction
it hit me in 1982 in episode 4 i tell you
about the trauma and how i deal with it
we make progress until we
are thrown off course if we
survive the catastrophe and
continuing on our path or falling depends on
whether we see our failures deeply
and make the right decisions
to reverse the trend
1982 was a fateful year when
everything settled on a depression that never
came the period from 1979 to 1982 was very
turbulent for the  world economy the
capital markets and for me i believed
that the us economy is
heading for a catastrophe with the world
economy this view was controversial
i want to take a high risk publicly
and was wrong
completely wrong after a
delay a bull market began which lasted 18 years
the us economy recorded its
historically  strongest growth i
felt like hat  te someone smashed my head
losses had to be cut so
my company bridgewater remained just an
employee i had to
borrow $4,000 from my father
to pay bills
worse i had to lay off valuable
employees
i am toying with the idea of
giving up my self-employment for a
secure job  to find and
drive to the office every day in a tie and suit
but less risk would also be less
quality of life for me to be so
wrong publicly was a painful
humiliation shock and shame at
my arrogance to have emphatically taken a completely wrong point of view
hold
on to it  i've been right more often than
wrong but this one misstep
negated all positives i thought about
the relationship between risk and
reward and how to manage it but
i didn't see a way that could bring more high
returns without taking reckless
risks it can happen
to anyone it will happen to you  pa  swhen you lose
something or someone essential or
you fall victim to illness or
injury or your career
unravels before your
eyes maybe you think your
life is over and there is no
solution but it will get better
there is always a best one  way forward
you just don't see it yet you have
to go
inside you have to accept the facts
episode 5 shows how i as a result
address the way reality works
and how best to deal with it
sometimes things happen that are difficult to
understand life often seems difficult
complicated and overwhelming my
heartfelt pain motivated me to reflect on my situation my thoughts
did not bring to nature
the guide of truth
i thought about how connections
work and found
a context for my circumstances
with the big when all the laws and forces
of the universe created
catapulted forward  and bye  influenced each other
in the sense of a perpetuum mobile
in which all the parts
to work machines join
together for a limited time then fall apart
and join together to form new machines
this process is infinite i saw that
everything is a machine is the structure and
development of galaxies the formation of
our solar system the  geography and
ecosystems of the earth our
economies and markets and each
of us each individual is a machine made up of
various
machines our circulatory system and
optic nerve system that
generates thoughts dreams feelings and everything else that
makes us personal
together these machines evolve and
produce the daily realities
i realized in a millisecond what
i should do
maybe this sounds like asking for
me it was useful because i realized
how i could deal better with my reality
so i realized that almost everything is
cyclical and endlessly m
repeated with tiny deviations some cycles
are short, quickly recognizable and simple
like the 24 hour day
others are long and have
not yet happened in our lifetime
and they shock us when they do it
like a storm of the century
some we know exist  but
we experience it for the first time how the
birth of a child
, situations are often treated as unique
without any perspective or
principles of action, wrongly processed instead of
qualifying them as exceptions,
each such situation
is another example of many that can be approached
with familiar methods is
that of a biologist  first
identifying the
species of an animal and then relying on its framework of knowledge these
events often repeat themselves in the
same way and with this also
the concept of cause and cause
which regulated them became clearer which allowed me to
develop better principles in
words and algorithms many expect
that d  he future is a variant of the
present i realized that the future is
very different looking
only at recent history
distorts reality events are
overlooked because they haven't happened for a long time
but they will repeat themselves
seen from this perspective i
realized  that i had overlooked patterns from the past
when the great
depression hit and i could use my
new knowledge to make better
decisions in the future
back to the question of balancing
risk and reward
i recognized that risk and reward two
sides of the same coin equals more life
means more life  taking more risks and
knowing how best to balance risk and
reward the quintessence of an
optimal life i thought
imagine you have the choice between
a safe boring life with no
big changes or a
wonderful life if you take the risk
into a dangerous jungle
traverse  n
this is the same choice for everyone for
me the choice was clear which is not to
say that the path was without challenges
i had to navigate two major barriers
in episode 6 i
share some valuable techniques
i can't tell you which
life path is best for you  is because i
don't know how important big goals
are to you and whether you are ready for the
effort to achieve your goals
that's the courage i talked about everyone
has to listen
to themselves after my bad step because of the
effective depression i stood at the
kreuzweg i would have played it
safe now and got a regular
job my life would have been different
but as long as i could pay rent and take
care of my kids it was clear that
there had to be a big mistake in my hunt for the best life
through the
jungle  but
i have a healthy respect for being wrong
i found the necessary deep
modesty the  what i had missed at the
same time i continued
to pursue my goals aggressively i needed more
than just my perspective of things
in the way there were two important barriers
the ego and the blind spot these
barriers have the more they are built by the
brain first diego barrier
diego barrier prevents a  objectively
recognizing your own weaknesses so that you
can then effectively eliminate them the
deepest needs and fears are
located in the part of the brain that
controls emotions and this part is not available for
the higher functions of
perception and it is more important to
be right than  learning the truth
we do
n't like to question our own
opinions we particularly like to overlook our
flaws and weaknesses
instinctively any criticism will
question everyone else as an attack on calm
we react angrily even when it
would be more logical to welcome feedback this is how
we learn to make flawed decisions
little and he  aren't our potential enough
now to the barrier of the blind
spot everyone has blind spots who think they
can see all aspects
forget their blind spot the fact
is that one person alone cannot grasp the entire
reality
what one cannot see one cannot yet
pay attention to parallel to the spectra  of the
different tones and colors there
is also a spectrum of recognition and
understanding some observers notice
general connections first
others see details above all
some think linearly others more laterally
some are creative and unreliable
others are not creative but
reliable and so on this
different perception of the  environment
is predetermined in the brain
we only deal with preferences weaknesses remain
unnoticed and failure is the consequence
one can carry on as before
or change aristotle defined
tragedy as a negative result that the
consequence of a fatal weakness of the
hero would be the weakness b  had been lifted the score
would have been positive i believe
these two barriers stand
in the way of good decision making my newfound
fear and being right finally gave me a
radical impartiality
taking risks and occasionally being
ruined was
unacceptable nor was
risk aversion and failure  top notch
results
i needed an approach to
achieving spectacular benefits without spectacular downsides
that realization turned out to be my
holy grail
i needed to replace the satisfaction of being right
with the satisfaction of knowing the truth
i sought the most thoughtful sweetest people
i could find and mine
I didn't share a point of view. I'm not interested in conclusions. I wanted insights into their
perspective and I wanted to
open up my perspective to them so that we would recognize
the true connections together
. In other words, I was
looking for a reasonable
opinion  difference away from my
perspective as the only one towards the
perspectives of such level-headed people
it was as if i had only laid in black and
white and now
the world lit up in color the best way to
get through the jungle of life is
to be with insightful people  who
have your own views
remember for the five
steps from just
because we are so different not everyone can do
all five steps well you do
n't have to do it alone
let others help you who have
strengths where you have weaknesses
those  other things
catch your eye than you get rid of the prejudice that you alone have the right answers use your fear of being wrong and practice impartiality towards other views this way you recognize opportunities
and risks that you would miss on your own
radical impartiality and
credibility when
weighing up views  have the probability
that o  making the best decisions
significantly improved so i was able to
master greater heights and challenges
earlier my opinion would always
have been decisive today i am
looking for the strongest
unbiased thinkers i can find
i will keep it up not better
than with special people the
unsparing truth and transparency
practicing
pulling together
with this approach i founded a company under the auspices of
a
meritocracy that works in a unique way and
has achieved unique results in
a meritocracy you get
the best from everyone everyone does preliminary work then
we resolve disagreements in order to achieve the
best result  but
not every opinion is equal we
learned to distinguish between good and bad
ideas in order to make
optimal decisions that means
the credibility different
approaches were weighted i will use
this in my work pri  nzip ian
delving deeper
in this moment you are surrounded by opportunities
and risks that you
cannot see if you could see the situation without the
distortions of the ego and dead center
the work would be more effective
mastering these skills makes
life radically better practice makes you
master
in episode 8 i finish our
journey together so that your own path can
begin
so far i have talked about how i learned
to confront my reality problems
weaken mistakes and how i
gathered like minded people to
compliment me it is the
most effective way to make quality
decisions it is  not normal being
there but this approach has made me
successful through my own
success i got to know extremely
successful people and their
ways of thinking we found things in
common
everyone struggles everyone has weaknesses everyone
surrounds themselves with representatives of
different perspectives
to neutralize their own weaknesses
ic  h realized that the greatest strengths
are coupled with the greatest speaking
the pursuit of the
extraordinary also leads to
painful setbacks
it is all part of the process
setbacks are trials that separate the wheat
from the chaff
some learn from a setback
and continue on the path to the goal
others throw in the towel and try
something different success is not
measured by achieving your goals
for me the achievement of each
new level of success opened the door to new
restlessness goals are nothing more
than lures the struggle to get there
forces a maturing process the struggle
for personal evolution  together with
others
this is the reward i no longer wanted to
traverse the jungle
i wanted to take on more demanding
challenges in
accompanying special people on
a common journey
the success of the mission and the
well-being of his companions became
increasingly important when  my own
success i started looking beyond myself
i wanted others to be successful
those who come after me if
i don't reach this goal i'm a
failure this is my current struggle we
fight until we give up or die
and part of evolution beyond  senses
will work like this all
machines will be recycled over time in the event of
a technical breakdown against the parts
back into the system and reinstalled on other
machines
it sometimes makes us sad because we
had gotten used to our machines
but in general it is
fascinating how  the evolutionary
machine works
you have to decide in which
direction you want to go it doesn't matter where these
principles of action come from
judge their value and adapt
them to your personal needs it's up
to you how you
deal with it my hope is that you have the courage to
do it  good fight
thank you very much  goodbye
[music]